what up brother how you doing bro i'm
doing well man i'm doing well
congratulations
on this first i just want to say you
walking up there on that stage accepting
this award you continue this whole award
season
you continue to be kind of the gift that
keeps on giving right anyone who watched
you
in this role i believe was changed but
then you stand up on that stage
and you thank your mother the way that
you did
i think you said what do you say uh uh
she gave you the factory
settings yeah the factory sentence yeah
the factory i love the fact that you
also you know
casually dropped the fact that you know
the situation of your parents
sex life on the oscar stage making sure
that your oscar speech lives on
in infamy is that going to live on
i think that's pretty obvious that all
our parents had sex but that's me
what's going on i just came out my mouth
i know my mom's probably gonna text me
some stuff
about that but um well here we are
it's coming from e.t kevin dan you have
you had a chance to talk to your mom yet
has she texted you yet oh bro no no no
no i'm gonna avoid my phone for a bit
mate
trust me i'm gonna avoid my phone for a
bit i think my mom's not gonna be very
happy
but she's gonna be cool she's gonna be
cool nice she's gonna be cool she's just
like she knows she's got a sense of
humor so she like we give it to each
other so it's cool
what does this mean for the hampton
family and also
the movement and what people may not
know about fred hampton bringing the
story to the big screen
and now you winning an oscar for telling
this man's story
i think there's just more people going
to watch um no chairman fred's story man
you know it's that's what it's about
that's what this was all about is about
telling the truth
and getting it out there and making sure
people see who this man was and what
this man did
and what this man continues to give the
fact that i can even stand on this stage
with this this statue is because of what
he did you know what i mean so it's i
think it's that it's just that
the legacy will continue and continue
and people want to engage with
the story in the film and the man
appreciate you thank you
next question is complex carla hi daniel
how are you this is carla from complex
hi hi then cola congratulations i'm so
excited for you um in this win thank you
thank you so much i wanted to you're
welcome i wanted to ask you
how important was it for you to share
this award with that cast but especially
with the keith
since you were nominated in the same
category
i mean it's it's a team effort you know
it's uh we did this together so
it's uh it's like again i shared this
honour with every single member of the
the cast and crew yeah that's awesome
thank you next question is sunday times
margaret
i was wondering what it meant for you to
win
with the world in the state that it's in
at the moment
um what it meant to win the world state
is in a moment um
it just you know it's amazing to have
this honor and to be appreciated in this
way
does it mean more for the community
though
does it mean more for the community uh
what means sign to the community is
people pouring into each other and and
and protecting each other and defending
each other and guiding each other that's
what means everything to the community
thank you thank you our last question is
coming from people tv
you mentioned there that you're back to
work on tuesday but tonight's the party
night maybe some into tomorrow what's
that going to look like for you
just enjoying ourselves man just
enjoying ourselves couple friends couple
vibes
thanks man congratulations appreciate
you thank you so much